bin in der glücklichen lage dass sie
wirklich zur richtigen zeit am richtigen
ort war
sie haben auch den genuss kauft den
zweiten generation flieger den sattel zu
fliegen wo es ein wunderbares flugzeug
war wunderschöne zeiten dort auch erlebt
und bis hin zu 5 und zum eurofighter den
ich heute noch fliege
das heißt also sehr breites spektrum der
letzten kommissar und 50 jahre
vor heimischen publikum mit dem roten
drachen war sicherlich ganz besonderes
highlight in meiner karriere
wer heute noch angesprochen drauf damit
samstag ist für die leute heute noch ein
begriff
und der steht ihr bei uns im militär
luftfahrt ausstellung auch unter schon
als gern hinter immerhin denkt an die
schöne zeit
natürlich erwarten die zuseher auch
immer wieder highlights neuigkeiten von
airbus einige sachen teil fahren lassen
eines meiner highlights die auch mit
sehr viel arbeit verbunden waren ist 60
jahre luftstreitkräfte was wir letztes
jahr gefeiert haben
auch bei der bahn kurze thematisieren
und ich versuche alle chats die jemals
beim österreichischen bundesheer
geflogen sind in einer formation über
dem steirischen himmel zu zählen
wir bitten alle zuseher daumen drücken
dass das wetter hält damit wirklich alle
teilnehmer die kommen auch fliegen
können
es ist so viele teilnehmer in der luft
dass wir leider nicht alle an beiden
tagen präsentieren können deshalb
daumendrücken gutes flieger wetter
braucht man dann wird es sicherlich ganz
tolle show